there's a lot of leaders who are plagued
by this which is we have to do it why do
we have to do it because look how much
time and money we've invested there's a
psychological bias which I write about
Ellie Aaronson a psychologist the
American psychologist one of my favorite
they got a group of people and they put
them into a very boring book club very
very boring everyone in there was
purposely intentionally dull and then
they asked them how good the book club
was and they all gave a score to see
these people that were put into that
then they've got another group of people
and they made them go through a rigorous
testing process and surveys to get into
the book club the people that had done
the rigorous testing and surveys and
applications to get into the book club
even though it was dull and boring
reported that the book club was amazing
and was much better than the people that
hadn't fought to get in there and it
speaks to this kind of like sunk cost
idea that leaders have where just
because we've worked hard on something
they tricked them themselves into
believing that it is good and then it
must be good that's it's a psychological
bias